hey guys welcome back to the evident
caitlyn podcast the podcast that is
perfectly balanced as all things should
be I should just start like saying
ridiculous things until I know we're
recording for sure that way like it's
just like a challenge for you to try to
make it into an intro oh yeah because by
the way I added the podcasts which is
why they're not great I was joking oh
there's a self-depreciating joke to show
that I myself like deprecating lower and
lower in value as well so in today's
episode we're gonna be talking about
work-life balance hence the amazingly
plan intro joke yes we have so much time
in life to plan interest and we are also
going to be playing the movie quote game
where we like try to guess there's quite
some fun game
yeah but we'll start off with some new
things have been going on with us and I
think that the main thing that's new
with us is we actually have a little bit
of work-life balance that we can talk
about yeah I guess the topic huh yeah
but you know we'll keep on going through
updates but I think they're like the
biggest update in our lives is that
we've been able to get ahead and I
didn't want to do a work/life balance
podcast until I we had like some ground
to stand on you know cuz honestly we'll
talk about it later we weren't that
balanced and I think it's getting to a
better place yeah yeah but I guess the
update is that we've been able to stop
working at like 9:30 or 10:00 every
night for like a week and a half
can we watch a TV show like stranger
things pretty much only stranger thing
only stranger things or or we play
minecraft
when we watch stranger things we watch
for the length of one episode won't
binge it we're like you know that was
that was awesome I feel like we had a
nice break let's get to better the
responsible responsible time and
minecraft we set an alarm and we say
we're just gonna play for an hour no no
the first time we didn't set an alarm
and we played until 1:00 a.m. I was like
no you set an alarm when we played until
midnight
yeah buddy because we're like yes we're
just taking a little tiny break and then
it's like 1 or 1 I think it's like the
people who go on those diets where they
can't eat any like meat or something
like that or they can't eat any bribes
they can't have carbs and then like that
it's like their cheat day or the end of
their diet and they just like go to
Olive Garden and get unlimited
breadsticks and all of the pasta and
it's like go go a little bit crazy I
think that's a little bit of what's
going on with us it's like we can relax
and take a break let's just do all of it
minecraft is addictive yeah you're like
falling down the Minecraft rabbit hole
and we are in the lava splashing around
we've mined down there minecraft rabbit
we have very nice and also on our gaming
channel I think that we feel confident
enough in our gaming channel identity as
a non minecraft channel that we're kind
of giving in to playing Minecraft more
and more well yeah we worried in the
beginning because we want to keep our
gaming channels kind of like the main
channel it's like we do projects but all
types of projects a gaming channel we
don't speak we play games but all types
of games like resin is the resin of our
gaming channel minecraft is the resin oh
right yeah we love it will always be
returning to it and it makes appearances
and other things about like our channel
isn't the resin Channel yeah and I gave
me - no who's in - minecraft channel
yeah but like almost yeah but it's like
a newfound confidence I thought that was
kind of word you have an update but for
the main topic work-life balance this
actually was a question that we got from
one of our patrons gene Jordan and his
question was how do you address
work/life balance or do you address it
at all with all the projects you two
have on your plate do you schedule
downtime or do you find ways to just
deal with not having any so so how do we
let us answer the questions in order how
do we address work/life balance it is
something that's a high priority for us
it's like our number one
priority at the moment number-one
priority but I also feel like we we've
had to be like realistic with ourselves
yeah
and know that it's it's not something
that we can really have immediately or
like from from the time we started the
channel autumn or do we knew it was
something that like we weren't gonna
have for a while well we knew that we
have with everything that we've done
with every project and path we've
started we know that there's a certain
minimum we need to keep up it's kind of
like a job because it is a job when you
have a job you have to work yeah to
accomplish a certain amount of tasks per
day and everything and for us our goal
has always been like about one video per
week on our main channel for the podcast
one podcast per week and for the gaming
channel it's like between one to three
videos a week and I think with each of
those we need to maintain that minimum
and now that we've established those
kind of goals we need to meet those
goals and then we try to free up as much
time beyond that so we try to reduce the
amount of time it takes us to do all of
those tasks so part of that was like all
the new cameras we got part of the
reason is we want our things look
prettier but part of it was because we
were creating a set up for ourselves
that would lead to less color balance
editing less audio yeah yeah less audio
issues you know we got some new lighting
equipment so that our lighting was
better and I didn't have to like boost
the levels the like the light versus
dark levels and premiere like all these
different things that make it take less
time to do the things we needed yeah and
I think that we do know we need to
continue moving in that direction of
like our better work/life balance so in
terms of how do we address it we it's
it's an ongoing large or like high
priority to-do item for us yeah and it's
interesting because it it's hard because
our work is something we really really
enjoy so I feel like if we were just
working a job that we didn't like that
much and we weren't happy with our work
life balance we could just be like well
I'm gonna try looking for another job or
I'm gonna talk to my boss and see if I
can change it not that those things
aren't hard but it's like there's a
clear direction in terms of like what
your ideal is and for us our ideal is to
have a better work-life balance but we
also really like doing the things that
we're doing and so it's work but it's
also really fun but it's also work it's
also really interesting one thing I just
thought of is for a normal day job like
you you you go to work and you put in
however many hours you put in you know
so it's like your performance and you're
like you know effort and everything
that's all judged by the amount of time
you put in and for us everything is
judged on like how much output we put
out and the quality of that output you
know so we have like kind of a minimum
deadline that we kind of need to hit
that we have set ourselves based on
industry standards and what we've seen
work and and stuff like that there's
other things that go into that but I
think it is very interesting because if
at your day job if your goals aren't
being met it's not really your fault in
a way you know you're like well you
should hire more people or you should
reduce the scope you know it's kind of
on the company because the company set
up the parameters wrong in a way but for
us it's like we set our own parameters
and there's no excuses that we can make
for the company doing poorly or doing
well you know it's like when it does
well that's us yes pride joy good
feelings but when it's not doing well
that's also on us sadness tears
disappointment bad feelings yeah right
because yeah because yeah you know when
you're when you're working for someone
else's company that's kind of on them
yeah I mean it's like you you kind of
care about your individual tasks but
overall performance of the company
usually usually doesn't have a huge
effect on your day-to-day yeah and
generally you want the company to do
well because you want to keep your job
and yeah you know hope to get a raise
you don't want them to have to do
layoffs all of that stuff is it usually
usually yeah but like yeah there's
there's no excuses and there's no
like well we should have hired more
people because if we that was the
solution then we should have done it
yeah early sales team needs to be better
yeah yeah it's like oh the sales team
didn't get enough information from the
customer so we weren't able to design
things right so that's on them no it's
like it's all us and we may have talked
about this before but every hour that we
don't work is an hour that we like
directly know the cost of yeah you know
so it does take a little bit more effort
to take breaks because you have to be ok
with that cost and until recently we
haven't really been able to justify the
cost yeah you know because we haven't
been able to get ahead in a really
really long time you know what actually
is really nice though one thing that I
realized just right now is some people
post like videos whenever they're ready
you know they have no schedule and they
say like alright so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna just like work as much as
we can and post videos as frequently as
we can and in some ways that sounds like
a little bit less stressful because
you're like well you know you can just
relax when you want to and you don't
you're not tied to a schedule and that's
more relaxed in some ways but at the
same time there's there's no where in
the future where they can say I am done
for now and I can stop for us since we
have a fairly set schedule if we get far
enough ahead and we're like good then we
can just like fully relax because we're
know we know we're ahead of schedule
we know it'll post two videos in the
same week on the main channel yeah yeah
exactly
you know cuz we've got kind of like a
little bit of a boundary for ourselves
of like you know what if we get that
video done that's and we feel good about
it and everything that's off yeah that
is that is interesting now we just need
to get there we're starting which we are
which we are yeah let's see in terms of
downtime answer that over the like
evolution of the channel ok a very
beginning we said the question was do
you scheduled downtime or do you find
ways to deal with not having any in the
very beginning we found ways to deal
with not having any you know cuz we just
knew that it was like full-on go mode
and in the beginning when you're first
starting up a channel it's like momentum
also you're starting up a business yeah
like yeah the business tax and you're
you're figuring so much out and I think
now we have more figured out and like we
don't have those big figuring out your
business to dues on our plate anymore
yeah that's that's very true it's not
like fully in maintenance mode yet but
the farther you are from that start
point like the farther along you are the
more in maintenance mode you get where
your to dues look very similar a week to
week yeah so I think that in the
beginning we said we'll just deal with
it and did we have any strategies to
deal with not having downtime no I mean
we like warned our family and friends
though like hey we may not see you much
yeah well I think the main the main
thing that we put into place is we said
do we know why we're doing this and we
did and it was all like for that goal
it's kind of like you know when people
have kids they're like well I know that
we're gonna not sleep much and we're not
gonna be able to see friends and family
as much but we know why we're doing it
because we're having this kid and we've
made the decision that having a kid is
worth it you know it's kind of like the
business we kind of said alright we know
why we're gonna do this and let's just
let's just get through it
it's gonna be worth it in the end yeah
because it works yeah yeah so we just
kind of like found ways to deal with it
we have been trying to schedule it not
not like officially schedule it but like
it the past week and a half or so we
tried to stop working after dinner
generally mm-hmm
that only works when we have dinner late
we haven't when we've dinner 8:30 yeah
we plan to stop working after dinner at
9:30 we plan to stop working at around
9:00 or 9:30
yeah we're 10 or 10 yeah no but like
that's better that's better that's
better yeah no so yeah we are you know
sometimes we do set a lot it's just like
1:00 to 2:00 or 3:00 if we're playing
Minecraft time hours to like take a
little bit of a break and that's so
valuable to us in a way to you because
knowing that we have that break at the
end of the day it helps you push through
anything that you're going through
mm-hmm in a way yeah like it
it really it I actually feel like it
makes me maybe take less five-minute
brain break I need to scroll through
ready yep breaks because I know that I'm
gonna get a break and I just want to be
efficient with my time even though I
know that sounds kind of silly that were
like so excited about stopping work at
9:30 at night you know but it really is
not like adding one to two hours of
relaxing time at the end of your day is
a huge difference it's an infinity
increase over zero yeah so yeah it's
super nice so a few things that we've
done I don't know maybe practical tips
that you could apply to any situation
who knows let us know if if any of these
make sense so for us what we did is
we've done we've looked at our to-do
list and remove anything that's not
important like or not benefiting us like
relationally to the time we put in so
that's that's been a purge that we've
been doing for a long time like you know
we had a lot of reoccurring - dues we
had a lot of things that like you know
we're long-term or whatever we went
through our to-do list and we kind of
experimented we're like well this has
been on the to-do list for so long let's
see if it's worth it like putting more
effort into our website at Evan and
Caitlin comm we I put in the time I put
in the effort it didn't make any
difference
and I'm like well now I'm going to check
this off forever I'm just gonna do the
basic thing that I've committed to I'll
just post the video and like the
description from YouTube but I'm not
gonna write out the tutorial anymore I'm
not gonna do all this extra time and
effort because I'm not getting the
benefit proportional to the time and
just removing that from the to-do list
was a huge relief from like our
perspective in terms of like yeah the
ongoing work that we have to do well
it's kind of like when you're trying to
clean out your closet and get rid of
stuff that you don't want anymore
it's all just there and you're like what
I don't really know I don't really know
what I should deal with or I shouldn't
do it when you're getting dressed you
have to look through all of it yeah you
have to look through all of it and it
like slows things down would all do for
that is kind of like what we did with a
to-do item we test it out yep like I'll
wear that shirt that I'm on the fence
about and if I don't like it by the end
of the day it's gone gone you know and
sometimes it's even though it seems like
kind of a pain to deal with those things
that might mer
not be worth your effort the ability to
remove them from your life is worth a
ver
is worth the effort so much ya know so
first off trimming off all the fat from
our to do this now we have a to-do list
full of things worth our time and when
everything on your list is worth your
time you don't we don't wear it really
worry as much about what we're doing
yeah you have you don't have to spend as
much time deciding
yeah and deciding what to do is a big
thing too you know so it's like as long
as I'm doing one of these items on this
list I know I'm spending my time well
and I don't need to self-doubt or like
doubt that in the mork's we've already
done all the work to decide that this is
worth it you know and then like third
getting ahead enough that you know we
can you can stop at a certain time I
think those three we already talked
about like the benefits of that but
those three combined have improved our
life and our work life balance a ton
yeah one thing I think you started to
say but I think we're both kind of
talking at the same time it's sending
alarms
oh yeah yeah like again this sounds kind
of silly but sometimes we have to set
alarms to stop working but I do think it
helps and I've heard of people do this
for like emails mm-hm
where you say except a 30-minute timer
yeah like it's super easy to get sucked
into emails so it's like I'm just I'm
gonna do emails right now I'm gonna set
a 30-minute timer and I'll do everything
I can do those 30 minutes and after that
I'm gonna walk away and not check emails
again until my next decided upon time
yeah you know cuz there are certain
things that you could just get sucked
into forever mm-hmm you know I think one
thing that that makes me feel good is we
have been aiming for this goal for a
long time and we have always said like
okay well when we have this done and
when we have this done and when we have
this done then we'll start relaxing and
taking a break and like you know
rebalancing how we spend our days and
we've like in the past two months or so
we've been slowly checking those things
off and getting our life to that point
and it has made a difference so that
makes me like really hopeful that like
yeah we thought we would get there when
we did those things we did those things
and we got a lot closer to that point
yeah I don't know well it yeah it does
it does
it's very hopeful and I think it has
been hard like
I know a lot of times because your
family lives in town so we'll see your
family a bunch and they'll you know ask
how things are going and ask you know if
we're able to take break so they say
that and it always kind of leads to like
well we're not taking breaks now but
we're doing stuff so that we can't take
breaks our future it seems like that's
what we've been saying for months no
first year or so yeah and see what my
family you know they'll ask like are we
taking a breaks like hey you guys taking
the time off this weekend and I'm always
like um but it does make me feel good
not only that we are able to take a look
a tiny bit of break but just to know
that like our vision and our plan is
working like we weren't off base it's
like and we knew it would take a while
we knew it wasn't gonna be something
overnight but it's good to see that like
it is finally starting to kick in
yeah like for example the garage oh my
gosh the garage was such a game changer
for us in so many ways yeah the garage
makeover we're talking about but like
you know big time investment things like
that and even now I'm continuing to do
some little things following up on the
garage yeah like we just like hung our
clamps at our clamps up and we repainted
this band saw of a brand we can't show
in our videos that we can like put it
out again and also like repainting it
was really awesome it looks great it's
gonna be great in the background now and
I think that those things that we're
gonna continue doing those types of
tasks will continue to improve our lives
yeah so it's kind of addictive to do
those at the same time so it's like
where's the line anyways I'm kind of
going in circles so what's an ideal
work-life balance look like to you like
ideal or ideal within the reason like a
reasonable range both okay
I mean ideal would just be that money is
no issue and we just do whatever we want
and there's no consequences this is
really interesting because you said
ideal is money would have no bearing on
things and we could just do whatever we
want but let's say that money was
removed from the day
completely let's say that we didn't have
to worry about money ever again but
would you still care about the
performance of our videos on the channel
that's why I added the factor of there
are no consequences
oh no consequences yeah so basically we
could just post whatever we want the
channel help doesn't suffer we can post
whenever we want we can do whatever type
of project we want
I mean how I think that's a less
interesting answer I think a more
interesting answer is what it is like
within the confines of reality well I
think it was kind of useful because like
it's interesting you unless you said
money it has nothing to do with it but
you still want like an a very important
thing to you oh for the channel to do
well yeah that's interesting to me you
know yeah I mean when we're looking at
our schedule and talking about our
schedule the main motivator for not
letting the schedule fall behind isn't
getting paid it's because we want the
channel health to be to do well yeah
you're right you take a buffer week this
that you know we still always have a
little bit of like I mean it hurts not
publish a video so much so it's not
because like oh we're not getting a
sponsor deal this week yes because like
it feels bad not adding another video to
our channel that's right
you know yeah and not not growing not
continuing to develop those weeks lower
you don't get as many views and it's
like oh is the channel okay you know and
we know logically that it's cuz we
didn't post that week but it's still
that's what is painful yeah because it's
kind of like the views and like the
growth is like the health of like you
know it's like like that the channel is
our baby and like the the health of the
channel is like the health of something
that we put so much effort into we don't
care about how much money our baby is it
healthy is it doing well in life how's
your day going yeah but I think I think
like a more realistic so there's like
different stages of my goals for balance
okay Stage one we're starting to get
there say one is I'd be okay working
every day even weekends and just
stopping after dinner yeah you know if
after
dinner every day we didn't have to work
I wouldn't even mind I mean cuz we work
weekends now that that's kind of just
like a slightly more relaxed version of
what we've been doing for the past week
yeah rubbing his eyes bigger ously one
of my hairs just on your face okay so
you're saying stage one
we're getting there yes stage one we're
getting there Stage two I think would
also be to take weekends off
even though weekends don't really mean
anything to us weekends is when like
everyone else in the world is doing
social things be friends or family you
know yeah and never know then we do like
we went out for brunch with some friends
last weekend you know and every now and
then you'll be friends or like if
there's like a family birthday or
something we'll get together on the
weekend so we do like take a little bit
more time for social things on weekends
but it's only when there's like an
external factor yeah like making us in
quotation marks I don't typically do it
just honor and we don't really have time
for like the after hangout you know it's
like we were having brunch with some
friends in there okay do you want to
play smash ah we have to go back and
film a video yeah you know we're having
brunch again you want to have you don't
play a card game we're like oh we have
to film a video you know it's like we're
not able to like fully dive into those
social happenings yeah but it yeah so
stage two would be being able to take
that time because it's a weekend yeah
and we're not working on week or all
right like yeah another thing we'd be
able to do with our weekends that like
doesn't really work as well with just
taking the last couple hours of the day
off is there's certain things we need to
do like we we both really need to go buy
new clothes and you sure oh my gosh my
shoes are from 14 years ago shoes are 14
years old sometimes were out and a piece
just falls out of the bottom of them and
like a part of your shoe came off I
think you shoves a pack about all my
glue back in later I completely lost one
of like the air like foam pads in the
back of one of my shoes so I got some
Evie a foam and I cut I cut out a piece
in the shape of the to replace it I
taped that in and now I have some
on my shoes yeah you know we could buy
stuff online but first stuff like shoes
also you could waste a bunch of time
online because right on weekends we
could take care of our lives some we
could like maintain our cars we could
like wash things we could like you know
things wash the car or something wash
ourselves we never we never no time for
showers but uh yeah I think I think
that's a good stage to Lowood stage 3b
or stage to complete I mean stage to
stage two I would be very happy with I
mean in the realm of within reason I
don't know if it would go beyond that
yeah you're right I think and in the in
the reasonable realm
I wouldn't expect ah like our type of
business to work or to be able to
function without with like less work
than someone puts into a 95 you're right
especially since there's just two of us
running like three channels putting out
about like sometimes three hours of
content per week that's a lot for two
people to make like you know relatively
polished content I mean I mainly think
about the podcasting is relatively
polished there's not too much polishing
that has to happen it so smooth
[Music]
speaking of smooth things I think it's
time for the game
[Music]
alright some movie quotes you want to
get your movie closer yeah okay so I
think what we did last time is Stage one
is you just read the quote yes you don't
put it like inflection on it or you
don't read it like the character and
you'll see if the person like an example
would be I'll be back yeah
Terminator but if I didn't get it yeah
then you get to go I'll be back ok ok
can I do it first one I'm excited
ok I'm a dancer I'm a damsel I'm in
distress I can handle this have a nice
day you want to see what is at the top
of my movie quotes list what I want I'm
a damsel in distress I can handle this
so that that's that's let's not keep
track of scores I don't want to do that
in the editing let's just say we both
win at life we can just keep track as we
go so that's it that's it that's that's
a draw yeah and it's Meg from Hercules
Hercules dang ok so funny so I could
redo since you ruined my first one I
ruined it really ruined it ok I'm gonna
make him an offer he can't refuse
that's the Godfather I thought I'd like
get you because that's I mean it's a
very famous quote but I didn't know he
did seeing the Godfather
I like I've seen parts that is upset
behalf of our audience ok I'm just one
stomach flu away from my goal weight see
I didn't just go to like top quotes of
all time hey III I googled obscure
quotes
oh yeah the Godfather one counts as
obscure know that the Megane wasn't
obscure one I'm just one start talking
first Bueller's Day Off no I'm just one
stomach flu away from my goal weight so
someone who wants to lose weight is it
is it live action yes can you
an actor who stars in it is it a movie
Epstein
I think so Meryl Streep is an actor I'm
not gonna tell you like the actor that
says oh no no no devil wears shoes no
Meryl Streep no oh the assistant okay
yeah that's really obscure thought that
obscure oh it isn't I mean I didn't want
to give you like super obvious ones but
that's like a that's like a pretty
well-known line from that movie's
well-known says Kaitlyn okay you're
gonna need a bigger boat jaws okay let
me do another one okay so so far we've
all gotten them though I mean you
required some systems so I would still
say I'm winning okay oh here you go
first
fifty million dollars man who do you
think you kidnapped Chelsea Clinton with
a hostage taken you're just saying
things that have to do with kidnapping
no you've been an actor have I seen it
yeah you've seen it is it live action
yes okay I thought it would be live
action because you know referencing like
a Clinton that would be weird if a
cartoon did that yeah that might give
you a sense of like the time this movie
came out um referencing a Clinton mm-hmm
let me read it again that won't help
that much I want me to say the first
part is yes 50 million boys oh I know I
know I know I know I know I know it it's
a Jackie Chan's in it too right yeah um
man I did a good impression he did do a
good impression oh you think you
kidnapped oh I know it's like um they're
cops
yeah rush hour yeah oh my gosh yeah
that's a good scene that was a good
scene I remember that's a good movie
yeah okay mine are too easy I'm looking
at all of them and I'm like the past can
hurt the past can't hurt um I feel like
I know this but the way I see it
oh it continues you can either run from
it oh oh oh my gosh the past can hurt
just don't dance like you're so good at
this game oh my gosh I know I'm trying
to think of like the context in which it
was said the past can hurt I'm saying it
in but the way I see it you can either
run from it or learn from it is that
another Hercules one no really filled it
and say that to Hercules No
are you want me to for me that want me
to give you a clue wait let me just
no no no no go I'll give you a clue okay
Oh Lion King ah I was like okay because
there is a similar line that Phil says
to Hercules
okay but I was pitching I was like I
know it's Disney I know one character
hits the other character on the head
and I thought it was like from the
training montage with phil and hercules
but I was like you already did a
Hercules quote it can't be that I
wouldn't do that to you okay - Hercules
is in a row yeah okay I took you up on a
line King quote I've set my laser from
stun to kill Oh mm-hmm
Star Trek no James Bond know from stun
to kill a laser there's a response to
this quote from another character that I
can also read if you don't get it yes go
for already that my leaves are from stun
to kill yeah the response is oh great
great yeah if anyone attacks um or if
anyone attacks us we can blink them to
death
men in black no that was the lasers my
laser from stun you know does the
character actually have a laser yes is
it a movie yes what what when did it
come out
um a while ago I better go a bit ago not
a new movie not really from childhood is
there spaceflight involved no no no
spaceflight it sounds like they're on
earth and they have lasers yeah
the old there's a laser I didn't say
lasers plural mm-hmm Austin Powers
humping the laser great great yeah if
anyone attacks us we can blink them to
death that my impressions aren't great
okay it's animated it's animated it's
animated that changes everything I still
don't know what it is three
animated 3d animated yeah not 2d that's
rare
Space Jam that's that's not 3d animated
it's not no it's to do you it's been a
long time
it's Looney Tunes they're cartoons
they're not 3d yeah you're right there
are some 3d effects with like the aliens
and stuff maybe maybe some maybe I don't
remember any okay well blink them to
death superhero related no no no stun to
kill what's the character's name it was
in terms of like 3d movies you know like
a lot of the movies animated movies now
yeah are 3d this was one of the earlier
ones oh I know what it is what is it
yeah well blink him to death there was a
laser it sounds like a laser pointer
okay and it was on earth there wasn't
space travel because I thought you might
think it was like to Star Trek or
something oh yeah okay okay I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna skip over them this
next one because it's way too easy
and I'll move to this greater good I am
your wife I am the greatest kid you are
ever going to get I literally have no
idea you've seen it I know you've seen
it greater good I am your wife I'm
literally the greatest good you're ever
going to get true um is it live action
nope
it's cartoon yes
so 2d 3d 3d okay 3d animated movies yes
with a wife yes um I'm just gonna Sarah
guessing uh oh wait no shoot what
someone there a whole superhero family
one of the Incredibles yeah yeah I'm
very good
I'm your wife I'm the Great Escape
you're ever gonna get do you remember
that one yeah it's um it's afros owns
wife when he's like looking for a super
suit and yet he's like honey where's my
super suit I remember honey where's my
super suit and now that was like I got
and then she responded and and he says
he said like it's for the greater good
and she's like greater good
I am the greater good yeah yeah yeah you
know it's funny is that's one of those
movies that I remember it when I watch
it I was like it was good movie yeah I
literally remembered nothing from it you
don't remember the plot do you remember
like the drama do remember like the no
capes nope you don't know the no capes
now do you remember like the designer
the little designer lady
I remember little designer lady yeah
yeah he did like the costumes you
remember like the wife lying to the
island and getting shot down by the
missile now the kid is sewing away in
the plane now I literally - that happens
me with some movies like that's like
every born movie every Bourne Identity I
watch it and I'm like good movie don't
remember anything nothing nothing
nothing's retained it you're amazing
mind nothing this is not room that's
what I'm thinking it's like that's what
my mind gets filled up with I could like
tell you the entire plot of The
Incredibles from beginning to end I mean
I can for a lot of movies it's not like
it's like that for all movies and it's
not like it's only like that for bad
movies it's interesting I mean what
movie can you like retell the plot for I
mean most like older Disney movies like
nothing I can say all Disney movies yeah
but that doesn't count cuz you've
watched those 20 times like a lot of
time so like a movie that I've only seen
once that I can retell the platform yeah
I mean it's hard just like think of a
movie like I'm trying to get something
older that I haven't watched Driss okay
spider-man into the spider burst can you
like retell like the plot yeah but we
saw that recently okay yeah yeah I'm
trying think of something that was like
older and also that's kind of I feel
like well I was thinking of like the
other spite like the first spider-man
movies cuz those I haven't seen in a
long time but then I was like there's
kind of a classic
spider-man story yeah so spider-man into
the spider-verse like was different
there's a yeah yeah no I can for some
even if I've only seen him once but then
like a lot of things yeah you're like
that that's not worth the RAM in my head
or like the long-term storage so you
dislike I think you have a lasting
effect yeah like it's not that I didn't
enjoy it it just didn't have a lasting
effect or anything for me to think about
yeah that's interesting okay yeah yes
nothing goes over my head my reflexes
are too fast
boo I know that I know that I know that
I know that I don't know what I would
catch it
[Laughter]
yeah I know you know it it I know I know
it III like as soon as you said like as
soon as you started saying it I knew the
rest of it is it live-action yeah is it
spider-man no a comedy yes as the comedy
[Laughter]
lady Marmol
it's a it's a comedic superhero movie
yes is it recent relatively relatively
about as recent as your guests x-men no
have we seen it yes
also keep in mind a lot of these
examples that you're saying like x-men
and Deadpool there are multiple of them
Deadpool - no but I'm just saying if
you're gonna get something like x-men
there's like 20 x-men movie this is a
movie no it's not is it a Deadpool movie
no oh jeez I go over my head I'd catch
it
Oh guardians of the galaxy yeah
this is Drax I think it's on the first
line cuz it was like when his character
was being introduced yeah and they were
saying like his kind they don't
understand metaphors it goes completely
over their heads and it goes nothing
close affirming I have to yes I like it
I like it that's a good one that's it
that's a good quote and it's a good
movie I endorse it 100% I'm so excited
about this I have a big head and little
arms I'm just not sure how well this
plan was thought out though it's um I
haven't seen this movie but like I quote
that line because you quote that I love
that line I've never seen it um there's
like a little kid with glasses and
that's what's dinosaur saying it and
there's like a bad guy with a mustache
yes but you voted so much but only that
one line it's a good movie it's a good
movie we should watch it it's worth a
watch I want you to meet the Robinsons
yes straight to it like you knew it you
knew it you know the movie you've seen
I'm not even sure if you've seen the
scene I don't want to leave that because
that well I would've had the same issue
I know it's from that movie but I
wouldn't maybe that would've guess the
[Music]
best start believing in ghost stories
you best start believing in ghost
stories miss Turner
no oh this is a scary movie have I seen
this Paranormal Activity no joking
the haunting the hunt no the which Blair
Witch Project it's not a horror movie
[Music]
some parts of it that some people like
kids might have nightmares from some
parts of it yeah it's not a horror movie
you'd best start to believe in in ghosts
mr. nur you're in one you're in a good
[Laughter]
[Applause]
start believin in ghost stories miss
Turner
this is an older movie no and we're all
sort of but not that old it's live
action
yes live action eat lead ghosts before
people started saying yeah okay okay
okay so more than five years ago is
probably on that on the high side five
years old probably not I think it's like
one year old we don't give up these
trends these use yeah you'd best ghost
stories you're just saying words
Oh Jumanji no no similar vibes in some
ways maybe Jumanji
I mean I'm an actor in it I feel like
the main ones that would be helpful also
might give it away Keira Knightley or
Tony about Johnny Depp yeah yeah yeah
okay thank you for the head I got it
yeah Geoffrey Rush you'd be like whoo I
have two left
mm-hmm and then I'm out dragon not
lizard
I don't do that tongue thing Oh
Mushu it's I should have stopped after
dragging my lizard I don't know if it
would have gotten it yeah I feel like
you need the you know one that I really
wanted to do with that from Mulan
dishonor on you dishonor on your cow
such a good quote okay get in loser rude
we're going shopping
get in loser we're going shopping get
Ferris Bueller's Day Off no you have
guests that like it's a good movie it's
very relevant a lot of clothes um get in
loser we're going shopping and see it
sounds like like an 80s movie or like an
like mm it was 2000s yeah we could've
been a lot of centuries it's just not
recently it's not like a movie in the
past like nine years this might is my
guess hmm it might be it might be okay
get in loser we're going shopping we
were in either high school or college
okay is this like loser seems like such
an outdated term now it said kind of
jokingly I know jokingly but not really
what's it kind of jokingly but not
really okay can you give me another hand
um it's a girl that says it I got that
Oh legally not legally blonde oh no no
the the girl she's in college high
school and she moved and she's in
popular and then she gets popular I mean
that's apply to a lot of movies so you
got to keep it going so I can make sure
you know it I think this she had the
same actors in Parent Trap or something
we're going shopping on Wednesdays we
wear pink yeah yeah I know I know the
movie now it's like and she pretends to
be popular so that she can like get into
the in-crowd and like switch there
another thing about girls in high school
they're mean Mean Girls
thank you for the hair girls in high
school they I mean okay my last quote
and then you get one more and then
that's it okay it's not right for a
woman to read soon she gets she starts
getting ideas I'm thinking is it the
Beast
yes dawn dawn dawn I was like that seems
like a very intro of Beauty and the
Beast thing that happens reading books
like it's not yeah it's not like I was
some good logic in there I can see like
I could literally hear the gears work
yeah because I didn't recognize the
quote per se but I was like oh that
feels like that would be oh yeah you
know that I was doing a lot of Disney
clothes yes they're fun
yeah last one hit me you sit on a throne
of lies Game of Thrones no just that's
the word throne in it you sit on a
throne of lies is it someone sitting on
in the throne there sitting but not in a
throne per se it kind of looks like a
throne but I don't think you would
automatically think of it as a throne
maybe if you didn't understand the
contact context of what you were seeing
you might consider it like a throne
because it's kind of like a fancy chair
is it Lion King no they said there's a
chair there's a fancy chairs like a bed
and a cage you know is that the the
Cusco movie where like that it's live
action you sit on a throne of lies wolf
of Wall Street it's a lot more
kid-friendly than a lot more it's not
necessarily a kids movie but because
like adults adults and kids could both
enjoy this movie mm-hmm so it's
live-action he's sitting in a chair I
mean you see the person saying it isn't
there's just someone that the quote is
directed to you you you sit upon a
throne of lies
you sit throne of dine lies lies said
very dramatically the person saying it
was very upset I get the feeling that
the person saying it was younger or a
female know there's an old man it's an
animal it's a baby crawling around Oh
it's a baby with you were the baby sock
the person maybe has the innocence of
someone younger but they're not young oh
yeah okay you gotta like it was like
some it was like there's some innocence
coming from the quote yeah you know
Santa yes throne yeah family chair fancy
sure yeah look if you don't know the
context it might look like a throne to
you yeah that's great that's great thank
you good job to you too I think moving
on it's time for thing of the week
okay so my thing of the week is a
wireless Bluetooth controller for
Windows Mac Android switch Raspberry Pi
and steam SNES controller but with the
modern buttons like two clickable
joysticks and four shoulder buttons I
should be like someone who reads ABS
yeah keep going you're doing great
that's it I like it so we're in the
midst of like a long term project right
now I'd only give too much away but we I
have to gather a lot of supplies I have
to gather a lot of things there's a lot
of research so I'm like slowly putting
together this list of her like this
collection of items the Raspberry Pi
last week was my recommendation that's
part one of the mechanical keyboard
mechanical keyboard and also now this
Bluetooth wireless controller I think
it's just really neat because I love
things that are multifunction and I just
love that this works with so many
devices you can like boot it up into
different like joystick modes which i
think is just really neat yes if you
press like start and then a button it'll
like because depending on like you know
the Xbox 360 controllers that we have
right here they use like X input which
is like one type of like like like
language of commands to send to your
computer
other other controllers use like a B W X
Y Z and stuff so it's like it's like a
keyboard so you can boot this controller
up to be like a keyboard controller or
an X input controller or an Android
controller and all of those uses
different protocols normally you would
need a different controller for every
single type of those applications and I
just like this one has all of them that
is really cool I also like that like I
like that it looks like a SNES killer
but it has like the triggers and the
bumpers yeah the triggers in the bumper
is like you can't play game games these
days without triggers and bumpers okay
and also I like that it's a lot more
portable than the Xbox 360 configured
there's gonna flat and compact and
compact yeah that sucks 360 user kind of
like bulky in fact that they have been
what we take with us on trips and stuff
before we bring in controllers yeah but
you know I love that you can pair it in
different modes to like different
computers and everything is just like I
just love versatile things and I like
a versatile thing that means that we can
get rid of more things that are like the
lesser versions of this better thing you
know that that's my pick of the week I
just was excited that I found something
like that so my thing of the week is
something that we have been putting in
resin is a resin hadn't it's a resin
added resin adjacent yeah it's glow
powder and we used it for the first time
in our resin knife video which came out
Friday and it's so freakin cool like so
freakin cool I like I just wished that
we had to put it in everything it'll
just be so cool if at night we turned
off the lights and I returned it they
turn into glue they were glue glue is
their glue all the time yeah I know it's
it's really cool and I don't really know
what I expected when we used it I guess
I expected it to be more faint yeah but
it's really prominent but it also didn't
discolor the resin at all yeah cuz I
worried like if we had enough that it
would show up it would also give the
resin like a greenish faint greenish
tint or something yeah and there's
different colors of this glow powder get
it in all sorts of colors teal what if
we got every single sort of glow color
and whenever like we're like mixing in a
resin if it's a purple resin it makes
them some purple glow powder if it's a
blue we mixed in the blue you know like
we can just do that for all the
different colors it'd be so cool and
it'd be so cool
I mean if we do enough glow-in-the-dark
resin things around the house we don't
even need night lights I mean yeah you
know our house will look like a magical
like New Zealand glow worm cave oh yes
oh my gosh you know we should make yeah
you know oh my gosh Oh coming back to
the 90s I like like buying organic
shapes or something or no no sweetie no
stars no no you know but we can like
make them like we could all we know we
can do we can do like Ghibli characters
on the ceiling too no stars I want or I
want resin ceiling stars we just buy
those
no I could well so here's the difference
they don't look very nice during the day
the ones you buy yeah just kind of look
like that light greenish color yeah we
can make them with really cool designs
so they look good during the day but
then it I think low or what we could do
is we can make a resin galaxy and just
put it on the ceiling the entire ceiling
the entire ceiling okay without the list
90s ceiling stars 90 ceiling stars yeah
people will know what we're talking
about that's the correct time yeah you
know okay you know you know so expect
that in one month or five months or a
year yep so don't expect it with an
engine engine time frame all right well
guys thanks so much for hanging out with
us this whole podcast I appreciate you
listening all the way to the end you
guys awesome yeah you get bonus points
and you get bonus points and also you
[Music]